my friend peter schiff recently went on
lewis howes the school of greatness
podcast i love peter i love lewis but
peter was saying some wild stuff let's
get into what peter was saying i'm gonna
go ahead and just point by point tell
you why he's wrong the dollar is gonna
take a huge hit i think in his
purchasing power in the next five years
yeah so people need to do something to
protect themselves so the bitcoiners got
that right of course the bitcoiners got
it right because the bitcoiners
understand the economy i'm glad that
peter and i both agree on one thing now
even though we agree on the problems the
gold bugs and the bitcoins we all
understand the undisciplined monetary
and fiscal policy we disagree on the
solution let's keep going with peter's
comments but buying bitcoin isn't the
answer to that problem because there's
no guarantee that the price of bitcoin
is gonna go up with inflation because
it's not tied to anything else uh it
doesn't have any actual value and nobody
actually needs it now here's the whole
thing about this peter first of all of
course nobody knows if anything is going
to go up in value nothing is guaranteed
the price of bitcoin going up is not
guaranteed the price of gold going up is
not guaranteed neither are stocks or
real estate the future is not guaranteed
the idea that something is guaranteed
would be absolutely idiotic but i will
tell you that although we don't know
what's gonna happen in the future we do
know what has happened in the past
inflation is at the highest levels in 40
years we have 6.8 percent inflation on a
cpi basis it hasn't been this high in
decades and gold is down 4
over the last 12 months even though
while we have high inflation gold has
failed as an inflation hedge bitcoin on
the other hand is up 66
over the last 12 months so if you're
looking at it from just a mathematical
standpoint well investors have chosen
bitcoin as the inflation hedge over gold
bitcoin's up and gold is down even
though we have high levels of inflation
now let's continue with peter's other
comments see the reason that gold is an
inflation hedge is because people need
gold they're going to buy the gold
people also need weed or oil or cotton
but you can't store millions of dollars
worth of cotton in your house but you
can store millions of dollars worth of
gold in a shoe box and you can use that
gold you can exchange that gold for
cotton or any other commodity you need
what we're talking about putting gold in
shoe boxes i don't want to store my
inflation edge in the shoe box i
actually don't even want to store it in
my house why would i want to take that
on and have to put it underneath my
mattress or in a shoebox i don't want to
do that that's actually a bad idea now
of course the whole argument that you
could exchange gold for cotton or wheat
or any other commodity is true you can
do that but you can also exchange
bitcoin for cotton or wheat or anything
else in fact if you go to certain
retailers they actually accept bitcoin
but they don't accept gold so of course
as we know bitcoin has served as a
better store of value with a environment
of high inflation but bitcoin has also
served as a better medium of exchange
than gold as well so i don't know what
peter's talking about here nobody wants
to put their bitcoin or their gold in
shoeboxes and of course bitcoin is the
better medium of exchange but let's
continue if money is losing value and
then all commodity prices are rising if
you can barter one commodity for another
well you know that's how you can save
your purchasing power that's why gold
though can be money because people can
have gold even though they don't need it
because they can use the gold and
exchange that for the things they do
need now of course yes you can
absolutely see that all commodity prices
are rising because the dollar is being
devalued remember the gold bugs and the
bitcoiners all agree the dollar is
getting weaker there is a devaluation of
the currency but bitcoin our favorite
friend bitcoin continues to outperform
all the other commodities bitcoin is up
66
over the last year currently sits around
47 000 per bitcoin and so of course
there are many commodities that someone
could hold you can change commodity for
commodity you can transact in them but
of course the best one is bitcoin
bitcoin is outperformed in an
environment of high inflation and it is
also the most popular one from a medium
of exchange standpoint i love my friend
peter lewis's podcast is amazing but
peter got this one wrong and that is
exactly why